this is asynchronous Python a gentle
introduction you have all won the survey
so to speak and you get to spend the
next 30 minutes or so doing this I do
hope that I can make it entertaining and
appealing this topic is full of
misconceptions the way that it's spoken
about even the way that existence some
of the documentation is is deceptive
which is why I chose this image to set
the tone so the way that we talk about
asynchronous programming or asynchrony
or a sink i/o or any of this we talk
about it as if we're doing multiple
things at once and yet interestingly so
what is the term for this in our culture
what we call this synchronized swimming
so already we see that the language is
working against us to understand what
asynchronous programming is like you
would think that would be it but we call
that synchronous it's a starting point
so here I'm going to define it and
disambiguate related but independent
concepts then talk about co-routines
you'll see why you know I'm just picking
very a small number of very important
topics and that is as such we'll do a
very brief survey of some
implementations but what I like to teach
you is largely implementation
independent and ideally is evergreen
material if if the material were no
longer useful next week well then that
would be that would be bad in the long
term so yes and first steps toward a
single D for program and some async IO
tips you will see that I have a
preference for that I am targeting only
a C Python 3.7 here to make this once
again last long and be useful and I
decided to modify the talk proposal I'm
no longer comparing implementations of a
program a realistic program using
different libraries but I can talk to
people about that
afterwards I'll be around so you know
III don't want it to be too much of a
bait-and-switch here consider this
information available to whoever wants
it this given that this is abstract
information you know let's let's do this
Socratic aliy don't hold questions until
the end and I will feel very comfortable
with no malice to choose to say
off-topic or we'll discuss it later and
we'll just go that route or like you
know we'll just obviously we'll discuss
it now okay yeah so this is really like
this is syntax low I think that a gentle
introduction to asynchrony being here
zan awaits syntax from async I always is
an anti-pattern it's it's it's really
not enlightening we are gonna take an
opposite approach here so okay we're
gonna start talking about processes and
threads threads have shared memory
processes don't
well processes don't share memory space
between each other so multi-threaded
applications or even multi process
applications the problem most of the
difficulty comes down to synchronization
which means even if they're doing
different things that you know and at
the same time even if they're doing
different things we eventually need them
to communicate at the end some useful
information to each other obviously and
then there's a whole subset of
information you can look at for
inter-process communication it is going
to be highly relevant to whatever work
that you're considering using
asynchronous programming for ah yes okay
so more more confusing terms being
cleared up for us all these are all
these terms thrown around so we have
this idea of concurrency versus
parallelism they are not the same thing
I happen to believe that the I really
like the definition on Wikipedia so I
cited it don't tell anyone
so but I provide that fold is
closure in like maybe you know get a
second source if you need it this is not
supposed to be considered canonical so
they are different so basically like
parallel computing you're doing two
different things at once
concurrent computing you you're able to
do two things you're only able to do one
thing at a time let's say but you can
divide your time evenly you know we like
to think of ourselves as multitaskers
and you know we're not really like
sometimes if we want to do a and B
simultaneously we really switched from A
to B to A to B to a and we pick up where
we left off of each another prerequisite
topic here to talk about pre-emptive
versus cooperative multitasking
technical difficulties so with
cooperative multitasking your code will
volunteer to give up control to I mean
often in the case of asynchronous
libraries some event loop or something
but the code is deciding that it wants
to give up control now this you know
cost notorious problems in like Windows
3.1 because if someone makes a program
that takes all of the that that doesn't
give up control then it's bad for
everybody else I mean this doesn't this
would be probably a poor way to
structure an operating system but in
this case if you and your team are
responsible for all of the code then you
can make sure that everyone plays nicely
no one will try and hog resources from
anyone else pre-emptive multitasking the
opposite this is this is the idea that
the operating system yanks control away
so as annoying as it is with cooperative
multitasking to consider other threads
when writing the current thread it's
actually easier than pre-emptive
multitasking because the code doesn't
need to be prepared for some external
force to steal it away without notice
all right and blocking versus non
blocking yeah so the idea of so and we
generally talked about this in terms of
IO cuz it's slow but it's not Iowa
specific so there is if I am running if
I'm using steps one two and three to
perform some task and step three waits
for step two well if it needs maybe it
needs to wait for step two maybe it does
not obviously it does it's a function of
whether or not step three uses the
output from step two if step two in our
program prevents step three from
happening until it's finished then we
consider it blocking so in practice
let's say that event two is I'm sorry
that action two is really going to town
and doing some hardcore processing well
then you know and this is this is this
is you know part of the height problem
here if that's the case then it would be
it wouldn't be useless for us to try and
make this somehow non blocking because
it would be occupying it would be
occupying the computer be occupying the
processor so the key word the key the
key idea here is while I'm waiting you
know if I'm waiting on something can I
do something else if if you if the if
the computer is already using its
resources then there there's then there
isn't there is no a benefit there so
asynchrony the technical definition is a
bit broader but uh you know we're it's
generally like we can think about it as
a style or a paradigm where we have
we're we're doing a single threaded
programming so one thread in one process
with a queue of non blocking tasks so we
set up a queue the queue we we execute
the tasks on the queue things are often
being added to the queue they're being
removed from the queue you can think
about this within the context of an
event loop which we'll get to in more
detail later but this is one thing at a
time I give this example of baking bread
while
dishes so I have two hands I need the
hands to perform baking tasks or to
perform dishwashing I can't yeah I mean
I personally I would be very impressed
if you were able to wash a dish with one
hand and bake bread with the other let's
just let's assume that's impossible
but please prove me wrong so in this
case I can do one or the other one thing
at a time but I can but my state is
retained when I return to my previous
context so if I go back to the dishes
the dishes are where I left off so it's
not as if I'm you know it's not as if I
do a task to completion then do another
task to completion then do another task
to completion the key here is that none
of these tasks are they're all stopped
before they're completed and then we go
use them again so it's commonly slated
ogo asynchronous it's fast what is their
speed boost from this well if we're
going to make things easy and just
compare single-threaded programs to
other single-threaded programs well the
the theoretical the theoretical maximum
game that we can get from this is that
we never have an idol we never have an
idle threat so I mean it's not massive I
mean we're not talking orders a
magnitude here but what okay we we could
be talking orders of magnitude I take
that back
it really just depends how it's a
function of how much the thread is
waiting now in a lot of certain a lot of
circumstances that people care about
like a like a web server there's a lot
of waiting there's a lot of waiting
there's a lot of latency issues
connectivity issues
other times I mean if you know if you're
doing like some kind of local heavy
number-crunching operation on your
laptop I mean if you're if you're
pulling from even your hard drive much
less external sources there might be a
lot of a lot of i/o that could block on
the other hand if you are just doing
lots and lots of calculation or
computation perhaps not just you know I
we look at this from the in case in the
out case in order to more fully
understand the in case it's it can be
useful to think about what a synchronism
or what it cannot do so you know I want
to thank Robert a small sure here I'm
using some of his slides because he's a
little more visually inclined than I am
so check out 60 North
particularly if you are based in the
United Kingdom so here we have some
visual representations of what I'm
talking about so let's consider the
orange and the red lines as we'll talk
about them as threads are generally like
each one is doing something so you can
see here concurrency versus parallel so
we're not we're not starting over every
time we do the concurrency but we can
really only do one thing at a time
however as we said if there's waiting
around then that can be much more
efficient so here we can see
asynchronous we don't wait before we
proceed we can start a task and then if
we if the control is released by that
task remember our cooperative
multitasking then we can move on to the
next thing and go back and look and of
course we compare this to sequential
often often takes more time
here's pre-emptive multitasking here's
cooperative multitasking tasks yield to
scheduler a lot of terms are used
similarly we should think about we
should think about the event loop as
it's so often called as a type of
scheduler so we'll think about an event
loop is a type of scheduler and I like
to think about an event loop you know
it's got the loopiness yes it's true but
like maybe it'd be useful to think about
it is like like a queue of tasks I think
it's useful to think about it there's a
queue of tasks as well as a loop because
you know we the stereotypical situation
is one in which we are just letting an
event loop run and it just runs forever
but that's I mean that's there there are
other common use cases for async Ione
are the libraries where we have a seer
we create a a queue of these tasks and
then we run them and then we relinquish
control flow back to some other more
classical more pythonic style of
programming so yeah so the queue is the
queue is even
more omnipresent than the event loop is
it on the event loop we can think about
it's a type of scheduler so let's look
at the color teens now so because this
is like the other you know big key
concept here so this guy donald knuth
you are probably familiar with so he
talks about so subroutines as we know
them functions you think about them as a
subset of co-routines a less powerful
version of co-routines generators also
called semicolons are between the two I
mentioned this so that you can take your
previous knowledge and apply something
alongside it rather than creates a new
concept it would be a waste so when we
think about a function or a subroutine
you know we have week we go in and we go
out we've got an entry point we call it
and then it returns a result so
co-routines can do that but they they
allow multiple entry points and re-entry
points for suspending and resuming
execution for non pre-emptive
multitasking so basically they're like
the foundation on which you as a new
asynchronous programmer are going to
rely on you're not going to be creating
event loops you're not going to be
writing libraries writing frameworks
like you'll be if you want to program a
synchronously using a framework you're
going to be using co-routines which is
why they're important now you can see
they're called task alerts generators
async await versus generator syntax you
know these green lights they have
different names they have different
syntaxes ASIC await and generator syntax
are both like see Python standard syntax
but you know we're looking we're trying
to look at this just just a hair more
abstract than that and and they're the
same thing
now of course there's just more broadly
there are generators that you know
you're you're familiar with and as you
recall they do they are kind of in
between if we think about a generator
like a generator does have different
it's it's it's a it's a less powerful
version of a co-routine so that makes
total sense so we initialize the
generator
and then we give it some input when we
start it and we have and then we we can
send it additional information we can
call next on it so we're suspending and
resuming the other really important
thing to know here is so a Co routine is
code plus state so when we see I think I
have so like here's here's code for
writing a an asynchronous co-routine so
we call this a KO routine function and
then when we call it we get something
back we get an object back that is the
ko routine that is the KO routine all
right yeah so these are the things that
Co routine can do you can await a future
results yield from same same thing
different syntax so you can await a
future or a KO routine future I wish I
had more time to get into a future we
could just think about it as a
placeholder for where a future value
will be which it's it's it's a little it
takes a few minutes to wrap one's head
around so don't worry if you don't get
it immediately it took me a while and
you know of course we can return and
raise an important part an important
digression here is this exception
handling is very nice let's think about
the way we might intuitively from the
ground up handle something like
asynchrony we might call a subprocess
for example there's there's not a lot of
control the fact that we can bubble
exceptions around in these things even
though they don't follow a stack or a
tree in terms of function calls because
they're co-routines and they're too cool
for that we can still we can still have
exceptions float around and that's that
is very helpful so anyway yeah here's I
mean you know I won't get hung up on it
but you provide it with an iterable and
a predicate when you when you initialize
it into a KO routine and then I mean if
you wanted to call this I believe you
could use you could use send on it um
you could send is like next but you can
you can add a parameter to it this looks
like it's
more of a standard like generator style
thing hey question
oh so this in this case predicate is
just an abstract way of saying like this
like you you pass it a function like if
you can see on line three you're passing
at a function that it will operate on
for the item so it's just like if you
can think about like if you like if
you're doing a more functional style of
programming maybe you might if you want
to do something to some strings you
might pass the function capitalized and
then inside of another function you
passed the capitalize function and then
you call it within so it would be yeah
so that's that's that's what's going on
there yeah he wanted to know what part
of this makes it a KO routine so a
really good hint that you're dealing
with the generator ko routine is the
yield and in this case this would mean
that you are that that you the control
flow is voluntarily given up so yeah
generally if you see a yields if you see
a yield you're definitely dealing with a
generator or a KO routine no yes there
are another question yeah this is this
is this is this is pretty similar to a
generator this is this is like misil
probably be a better example if yields
was waiting on a future value for
example like using using a weight or
using yield from yeah I I probably
should have used I probably should use
the different different co-routine
function but yeah and and obviously one
function any any given Co routine or
subroutine within itself you know there
are there are no clear benefits of
asynchrony there we need to see how this
would play with other functions I'm
sorry with other Co routines in order to
like really understand the benefit yeah
because if you just have a single Co
routine it's basically as used as useful
as a single subroutine
so we'll talk about event loops so okay
so let's think so we've got this
concurrent style where we can sort of
put things on pause and resume them and
this can be very useful you know if we
think about like these so if we think
about like an event loop this is where
you know we're adding things too
you know we're constantly adding tasks
to this queue and we're constantly
executing them basically like for async
IO speak we make a KO routine into a
future so we're just like kind of
thinking about like what's the next
value that the Coe routine is going to
yield
we'll make that into a task so and this
is once again it goes back to the shared
state like if I have a KO routine if I
if I've covered one Co routine function
there could be ten co-routines of it
because remember it's we call that and
then we add state and maybe each one of
these is some certain amount of the way
through because we can vault we can
volunteer away execution control
cooperative multitasking again and then
get it back so they're they're kind of
all over the place
so and there is if you really have to
use something that's blocking or
something long-running you can use an
executor there are multiple there are
two different types of executors that
are in the Python standard library it is
kind of like an easy way to spend
something up to do a task that maybe you
don't want in your event loop so yeah
it's all right
oh this should be first so I mean here's
here's an event loop you know we've got
like eight eight slots let's say we put
something in a slot we're kind of
imagine us spinning around this and you
know this kind of like the dumbest
possible event loop so we've got this
task queue one through eight are tasks
this one is smarter where and this is
actually the one that is let async i/o
uses so instead of just blindly running
around and checking like hey does this
does this guy does this task does this
task need anything does this task need
anything
you know here it's it knows to look a
bit smarter it's got I guess a higher
hit rate so let's talk about why this is
difficult so the feedback and the
failures are subtler I mean as you know
I I think that we can often be spoiled
if we're a software if we're doing
software engineering because we get such
wonderful feedback of a failure worst
case scenario we complain that that
there's a non-descriptive error message
but I mean imagine most fields I mean
most fields would kill for just you know
free validation in like half a second in
this case you could I mean you can you
can be in a situation where like you
know perhaps the code is say running
like there's a blocking function call
you run it it looks the same I mean you
can you know try timing these things and
then I mean but then you're getting into
like empirical or statistical ways of
validating I mean its Messier so that's
so that's tough and then the other thing
is you know the very nature of like
voluntarily giving up control you're
worrying about what other threads are
doing you're worrying about things that
are going on outside of the same like
code space as well as what you as you
know wherever you happen to be in your
text editor or what-have-you
you have to think about things that are
going on outside of that so it's similar
to different to thinking in a different
abstraction level simultaneously which
of course people do with low-level
languages whatever but yeah you have to
be concerned about that and that's
that's that you know that everything
probably requires some new synapses to
be built so some first steps toward
asynchronous so we talked about here
scaling here maybe processes we get tens
you know of you know simultaneous paths
of execution threads hundreds async
we're talking thousands here now of
course that's because you know a single
thread like you know threads are a
little heavier they take more RAM
processes even more so so I mean once
again you know you're not getting
thousands of times speed boost in like
the the theoretical sense but
practically if you have say a web
and there are 500 people all using
typical like cell phone data plans is
something then then in practice I mean
you're going to be able to you're going
to be able to handle all of those
connections because they're all just
going to use the same they're just going
to they're just going to use the same
the same event loop the same thread
what-have-you so they're light they're
light but with the caveats that I gave
earlier so first steps toward a
synchrony ask if there's a package to do
this thing there often is a IO libs is a
wonderful collection of packages they
the curate them I mean just you know
practically speaking it's nice to have
something practical in this discussion
right so like you know check if you need
to what you need to do asynchronously or
what you can what you're considering
doing asynchronously asynchronously
there's probably like you know database
calls you know HTTP requests whatever
like you know that's those are available
that's around whether or not you have
this I personally I think that the async
i/o is is going to be you know the best
bet you know if you're talking three
seven and onward greenfield project it's
the doc is a ton of documentation it
encompasses both high and low
abstraction api's I mean we don't even
have time here obviously to get into
like protocols or transports or like a
lot of the like like I mean people you
you you can use async IO to build
something that's high level like it's
just it's it's got like you know you can
think about this this awaits async
syntax that people love so much it's
like a real tip of the iceberg I mean
it's just it's just massive so and
there's some history here as well so
stackless python is probably the oldest
thing on here it allows task lists which
are like these like co-routine futures
it's like it patches cpython I think
don't quote me on it and then so
greenlit is a spin-off of stackless it's
just good to know how these things are
related and you know green lets an event
let ng event lits ng event used green
'let's whatever g event is inspired
Green that you can tell there's there's
a lot of incest here there really aren't
that many like projects that are like
doing the quarry synchrony when it comes
down to it and then here's curio on trio
which it's useful for you to know about
their New Kids on the Block more very
practical stuff
use Python async IOD bug when you are
running code locally it will help you a
ton it will give you warnings and errors
that will otherwise not be there and
they're helpful and they handle like
this ugh this crazy new style of
thinking where you have to worry about
other threads when you're worrying about
other other tasks when you're worrying
about your own tasks another thing to
consider is releasing releasing the
tasks once in a while via something like
you know async IO dot sleep and you just
sleep zero and that says hey I'll
volunteer to give up the task but that
sometimes less important if you want to
know when that's less important than
talk to me afterwards the blocking
library functions these are incompatible
you won't necessarily get an error but
these are blocking so you will not
receive benefits you will not receive
benefits of asynchrony because they'll
block further reading please refer to
the work cited there's this guy and
there's this guy X extra thanks to
Robert small sure and to Sebastian I
don't where so it's Sebastian mapped out
over here as well as of course everybody
else so you should also know that I am
seeking pan industry Python contractor
work and a job in finance do you have
anything for me let's let's let's do
some cues in some A's we got a few
minutes and I would love to be able to
get some questions do we have any ok
this fellow yes
he wants in it he wants in an example of
a PI data a PI data friendly example
okay if you are if you are doing if you
if you need to make a calculation for
which a prerequisite for the calculation
is doing thousands of HTTP requests then
you will be able to do them you will be
able to do those requests those API
calls much much much faster if you go
the asynchronous route do we have
question in the back
are all of the co-routines on the same
CPU i will one-up you they are on the
same cpu on the same thread and I think
that's that's probably what people don't
understand and that's and that's why you
know there's really there are not really
two things being done at once it is not
parallel asynchrony is not parallel
you're doing one thing at a time
executors aside quest question in the
front so the question was is the burden
completely on the developer to decide
when to switch context asynchronously
versus if someone's doing something more
pythonic lee is it is it decided for you
I that's I mean that's it's it's nuanced
i I will actually I would be happy to
talk to you about it afterwards like
vault I mean I I promised I would talk
to you about that multi-threading yeah I
mean if you're multi-threading then yeah
I mean then you can do things in a
parallel fashion but I actually I will
address do we have any other questions
are we good on time okay uh so I saw one
over here maybe
all right this fellow
yeah yeah
so I specifically like only looked at
the documentation for three seven I know
that like yeah I'd like the a ace the
async and await keywords are pretty new
I think they're like three five or three
six I mean I didn't go out of my way to
like make it backwards incompatible like
when possible like it's good that it is
I just I did I did not want to consider
a three six and before but like pretty
much everything I'm saying is like if
you have three six at home like pretty
much everything I'm saying will like be
completely accurate okay oh wait we got
a question so he said how to so he asked
how does a weight work so a weight is a
a nicer more async I Oh way of writing a
yield from and yield from is just where
we relinquish control to another future
or Co routine and whenever that future a
co routine pops up with an answer then
we we we go back to the parent Co
routine with that it with that result
I mean it's a that's no that's like yeah
I mean it's right you don't and your
practical purposes no you don't have
direct access to the future but you can
you could you do have access to its
result whenever you're lucky enough for
it to arrive okay so we are we are
finished I do thank you very much please
look around for me ask me questions talk
to me thank you very much for attending
I do appreciate it
[Applause]